the Joe Rogan experience boom and we're
like you're the first guy with a high
top ever to wear these my I was
wondering whether that the microphones
were gonna sit it's perfect yeah it's
just writing this like little crispy
like a little rest area does that have
this this having that much hair on the
top of your head is there any benefit of
that I think we get like elbowed or
anything like that I think it helps out
a ton like if someone if you have
someone in their guard and they're
trying to elbow the top of your head I
would imagine yeah it's a little cushion
on it so it I think it protects you and
I kind of grew up the beard for that
kind of the same reason but it doesn't
get as burly as I kind of wanted to but
it works I think in boxing they used to
make people shave their beard yeah
that's probably why in Para I you know
that kid desi green I used to live with
him using a you'll see also mm-hmm and
whenever I put that guy in the gate
because he has these big dreads and he
would always get out of them because the
dreads were like it gave his head it
made his head appear like it was bigger
so you wrap around it and you squeeze
the cushion and it just compresses and
then he just his head just slides out of
it completely
so it's like a cheat code slippery
slippery dreadlocks
I would also imagine though that having
a bald head if you get sweaty would make
it a little greasy ER like if you have
stubble like on the top of your head
that would provide like a little bit of
friction yeah it makes sense I I follow
you I follow you on that I haven't had a
bald head though so I don't I hard for
me to do you know I like how your shirt
even has a gold chain on it I was gonna
wear the big-boy chain today but uh I
don't know I don't know you only carry
that out when you fight I usually do I
try to keep it not like too ridiculous
all the time you know try to be like
only in character like make it for like
it's like a special occasion type of
thing
there's even I would consider this a
special occasion but try to make it more
of a like an MMA thing oh there's
something extra special about a t-shirt
with gold chain on it might be more
special than an actual gold chain itself
it works so it's the kind of silly yeah
man how much does that thing weigh the
real one um not very heavy nothing which
is like ten pounds now I wish it was ten
pounds I'd be ten pounds of gold but uh
it's not this was like an Easter Easter
Bunny but yes this harlot is that thing
is massive right
so is it hollow there like hollow tubes
yeah you think they'll be so heavy you
think I get a lot of people that come up
to me and stop grabbing my chain I'm
like oh yes this is supposed to be a
mystery you know today the human mind
you're not supposed to know what this
feels like
you know it's really like I spent like
$25,000 on the vs go rope chain but uh
nah we remember when rampage used to
wear the motorcycle chain
yeah the links yeah real heavy links
around his neck I was gonna actually go
there was two routes I was gonna go the
old-school route with my chain like the
way my dad used to wear it and how we
used to wear when we were kids or
Rampage Jackson and be like the new
generation of Rampage Jackson even I
wasn't like slamming people but I would
have to like somehow work
[Applause]